e-gates are supposed to speed up
arrivals but at many airports things
ground to a halt some passengers had to
wait hours upon Landing after the
machines that automatically check
passports stopped working Nationwide
Darren was caught up in the chaos with
his family after flying home from
holiday in Spain there must have been
about 5 000 people you know kind of
queuing to go through
um and it was just so hot and unbeatable
at some points
as we were walking through it kind of
just got a little bit intense and
obviously waiting with my family the
problem began on Friday night the cause
unknown but it meant all passports had
to be manually checked instead it's
perhaps no surprise that we're seeing
these e-gate systems fall over there are
record numbers of passengers arriving in
the UK this weekend the busiest since
2019 the systems have been under
invested in over the years and they're
creaking at the seams that puts more
pressure on those individuals who are
processing our passports manually they
might miss something which the e-gates
would otherwise have picked up and that
could pose the dangers to National
Security those trying to leave the
country have also had issues ba
canceling 175 flights ahead of the
weekend after an I.T fault of its own a
computer glitch was also blamed for
delays at Dover this time at the French
border control but problems persisted
even after it was fixed about an hour
and 15 minutes hour of 15. how does that
compare to normal I've never experienced
these problems at Dover before you
travel through yeah you haven't so yeah
we've not identity I don't do that have
you have you made your Ferry oh no it's
not as bad as it seems is it we've been
delayed of an hour double the amount of
time we needed to get you and have still
missed our chicken for our fairy so not
quite sure what we're going to do next
but we'll just have to wait and see
disruption here though is nothing new
and it's not all electronic since brexit
border checks here simply take longer
than they did before for cars it's
around 90 seconds but for coaches it's
up to 15 minutes and when you have
thousands of vehicles coming here all at
once queues are the inevitable result
and this time it seems there was no
Escape whatever your mode of Transport
where they're coming or going another
holiday getaway that's begun with going
nowhere fast either Bennett Sky News
Dover